it is time for hatred mail I will very
quickly remind you what is hatred mail
because the government that is
supposedly totally inept is the same
government that can pull off a
conspiracy that will blow your mind
patriot mail written by Patriots who
hate David Pakman because America and
because freedom alright sometimes hatred
mail requires an introduction sometimes
hatred mail wants an introduction
neither is the case this week let's just
get right into it
David Joo Pakman saying cringe cringe
Pakman just cannot help being a
subversive Jew it's in his blood every
time his videos pop up I'm reminded of
how much of a fake and an elitist he is
playing drums traveling to Europe
driving a car in Boston David always so
naive and elitist
oh yeah David super-delegates are bad
okay's bad Jew his is playing drums
considered elitist I actually didn't
know that I know go Europe is certainly
considered elitist in American
right-wing circles anything European is
elitist and a very beta for people who
think of the alpha beta male paradigm
but just playing drums is is elitist
driving a car is elitist now very
strange I feel like the attacks are
becoming more and more flaccid but I
will remind you that you can use the
coupon code hey tree at 40 to save 40%
off of a membership at join pakman.com
and when you use the coupon code hey
tree at 40 the hey tree 'it's are
miserable because they see that their
attacks are only growing support for
independent media